if you fall i will catch you oh i'll be
waiting
time after time
time after time
time after time
donna
oh my god i am so excited to see you
here these things are horrible when
you're by yourself
what
do you know where you are right now
we're in the jungle there are no friends
here it's every woman for herself
you're joking right do i look like i'm
joking
dating is a zero-sum game
if you get a man
i don't get that man
i'm here because of advice that you gave
me to be more adventurous in my life
here's some more advice
beat it
hi i'm anne brian
what's your occupation i'm a manager at
a sporting goods store no way me too
seriously which one no i'm not um i i
was just ribbing you
what are you drinking
yeah
what
oh i don't know i i couldn't hear you
so you just laughed and said yeah yeah
excuse us
that was the worst thing i've ever seen
in my life did you grow up in the woods
or you know
from the movie mill
you always want to scribble the name
make them read
draw them in make them work for it
right
two shots of jameson don't make too much
eye contact you want to seem available
but not too available
thanks i think i'm good for now i'm not
gonna yeah
because
all right
let's do this
are you okay
what is it your heart are you having
trouble breathing
are you gonna hit that
him
he isn't exactly boyfriend material who
said anything about a boyfriend use him
abuse him
lose him
dj butts is in the building he'd
announced that tom haverford is in the
building
[Music]
three words for you treat yo self
treat yourself 2011
once a year donna and i spend a day
treating ourselves what do we treat
ourselves to
clothes treat yourself fragrances treat
yourself massage it treat yourself
mimosas treat yourself fine leather
goods treat yourself it's the best day
of the year the best day of the
[Music]
year treat yourself in beverly hills
hey hey hey
donna come here
right here please right here ladies and
gentlemen off to our right you can see
the house that belongs to bruce willis
and christina aguilera and to our left
is usher's los angeles residence halls
[Applause]
[Music]
what some fool just slammed me on yelp i
took ron's advice i very maturely and
straightforwardly left anonymous
comments about donna online
stop by to adopt a dog but the employee
donna meagle was nowhere to be found
thanks for nothing donna meagle boo
with five o's oh my god that sucks just
have to work harder i guess huh this
freak thinks he can hide behind some
anonymous username i'm about to hunt you
down
just give me the ip address of the dude
that gave me that cracked out yelp
review
okay here we go the ip address says it
came from someone inside city hall in
this building oh hell no well who cares
really it's just some dumb internet
person ignore it ignore it i'm about to
calm down on this dude like thor's
hammer mjolnir
i'm about to go mjolnir on his ass i
don't want you to get recalled nope but
damn these people know how to pick a
neck massager and before you get on my
case about those stickers i already did
them donna there is trouble of brewing
we think that you may have accidentally
tweeted from the parks and rec account
rather than your own personal account uh
oh
what'd it say see you tonight hope you
like tongue baths you big nasty firemen
then there's a picture of a pair of lips
and then a picture of an eggplant i'm
both confused and if we're being totally
honest a little aroused
not to give you too much of a peek into
my personal life but this could have
been way worse what's important is we
deleted the tweet and nobody is going to
know it's you but donna you know be more
careful in the future this could have
really blown up in my face
[Music]
i'm here live at a press conference
where councilman jeremy jam will discuss
a government scandal we are calling
twitter watergate until we can find a
snappier name for it
tongue baths
eggplants
firemen
those men are heroes who deserve respect
911.
this is how leslie knope runs her parks
department we are going to hold hearing
after hearing until we are satisfied
this will be blown way out of proportion
you have my word on
oh this is bad i'm gonna get fired no
one is getting fired okay jam is trying
to use this to hurt me in the recall
he's trying to take me down and he's
willing to attack my friends in the
process no no way not on my wall not in
her watch he is not gonna sully your
name no sorry ain't allowed don't worry
about it donna we're gonna nip this in
the butt guard your buds cause they're
about to get nipped okay okay
oh my god
oh
look at how beautiful you look leslie
i'm not even in my dress yet but you're
gonna be very soon all right i want to
say something to my girls
nope you're a softie but on the inside
you're a straight-up boss april you're
the exact opposite y'all inspire me and
i love you
and you too michelle
michelle you were my best friend from
childhood until we lost touch because
you thought your college boyfriend was
into me he was
i never gave him the time of day but now
we're revealing her friendship
is this wedding gonna be a test for you
yes but the doctors once told you you
were never going to walk again so this
should be easy right wow what a
complicated tapestry that is break it in
i guess we can make a switch to bermuda
grass it's only 80 cents more per square
foot what
give me give me give me
you want me to put bermuda grass in a
continental climate that's a six on the
beaufort scale in a park with zero
drainage i want kentucky bluegrass i
want a 10 discount and i want you to
apologize to my best friend donna
yeah hi is there
and i'm just guessing here's some kind
of medication that you maybe need a lot
of and have taken none of or maybe too
much of today oh i have i have a medical
condition all right it's called caring
too much and it's incurable
also i have eczema
i would like to address the goofy
looking dirty kimono wearing cornrowed
clown in the room if you see ron swanson
can you give him this message
you used to be a man you need to get
your house in order look i love you like
a brother but right now i hate you
like my actual brother levandrius who i
hate
okay our official co-parenting score is
58 compatibility
not amazing oh i think it's fantastic i
think it's literally the best score we
could have hoped for
not sure that that's true oh snap i just
filled it out for fun chris and i are 81
compatible
you want to make a baby tracker
your hair my everything else that kid
would be unstoppable
let's talk about personal relationships
who wants to start donna i have several
men in rotation
one's waiting for me out in the car
don't worry roll down the window welcome
to nirvana the plaza at eagleton there's
a reflecting pull out back there's an
old-timey train that runs through the
mall and three burberries if you tell
your friend hey meet me at burberry's
they gotta specify which one
let's hit it
i really want this dress and i like this
crystal beetle but it's expensive and
there's no use for it
donna meagle
treat yourself
velvet slippies cashmere socks velvet
pants cashmere turtle i'm a cashmere
velvet candy cane treat yourself
donna what are you doing here so early i
come bearing gifts first off i got to do
the maintenance to open up that grate
this morning so here's your rings keys
credit cards and i found some heart
medicine i was on there no that's mine
that's fine oh my gosh also i thought
i'd bring over some fresh oranges for
you and gail
okay well that was just so kind donna
thank you you're one of a kind gary
and i just want to thank you for taking
me down memory lane
you big b word
buddy
you